The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we're
going to continue
talking about LTI systems
and how to work with them.
We're thinking of an LTI
model for a channel, something
with input xn, output yn.
And we've seen
that the output can
be obtained from the input
through this convolution
operation, right?
So for instance, this
was one way to write it.
And the shorthand notation
here was h star x,
evaluate to the time n.
The m here, in general,
goes from minus infinity
to plus infinity.
In general, you put a unit
sample function of the input,
the response can extend
from minus infinity
to infinity if you've
got a non-causal system.
If you've got a causal system
and you put a unit sample in,
then the response starts from
0 and goes on to the future.
But it's often useful to be
able to represent and analyze
non-causal systems.
I mean, if you have all the
data stored in your computer,
then you can look forward
and back from the time
that you're at.
And therefore, you
can do things that
can be looked at as non-causal
or analyzed as non-causal.
Now, there's one issue
that we've kind of swept
under the rug, which is you can
write nice looking formulas,
but do they mean anything?
So we went through a
plausible derivation,
but if you end up
with a summation
from minus infinity to
infinity, then you've
got to ask yourself when
does this make sense?
Because you know that adding
an infinite number of things
can cause problems.
So you need conditions for
all of this to make sense.
For instance, if h was 1 for all
time and x was 1 for all time,
there's no way this is
going to make sense.
Because it's going to blow up
at every value of n, right?
So you clearly need conditions.
So what we're looking for is
conditions for convolution
to be well behaved.
And I'm going to give you
one important condition.
Well actually, let
me give you two.
So here's one.
Suppose we have a causal
system and input that
starts from 0 at time 0.
When I say starts out, I
mean that for all prior times
the input is 0.
So we've got an input that
is 0 for all negative times.
And then, at n equals 0 we
start to get some action, OK?
So let's see, what happens
to this infinite sum
in this particular case?
If I have a causal system,
that means that h of n
is 0 for n less than 0, right?
That's what you should
think of right away
when you're told a
system is causal.
The unit sample response can
only extend from 0 onwards.
So if the unit sample response
is 0 for a negative time,
and the input starts at
time 0, what simplifications
can you make to that
convolution representation?
Somebody?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 0 to
infinity does it?
OK, so the answer
was that instead
of starting at minus
infinity, you only
need to start the
summation at m equals 0.
Because the h of
m is going to be
0 for all negative values of m.
So you can start
that summation at 0.
And then, where
does the summation--
where can the summation end?
AUDIENCE: n?
PROFESSOR: n?
Yeah, because this x here
is 0 for negative values
of the argument.
Negative values of the argument
are values of m greater than n.
So this only needs to
extend over a finite region.
Well, if you have a finite
sum, then you're happy.
Nothing's going to blow up.
So this is certainly one case
where everything works fine.
There's another case
which I'll describe
which is where your
input is bounded
and what we mean by
that is that your xn has
an absolute value
that's less than
or equal to some maximum value--
some finite maximum
value for all time.
So no matter what
n you pick, you're
always within this interval, OK?
So your input is, here's
your n, here's your plus m,
here's your minus m.
And your input is
constrained for all time
to just lie between
these limits.
So that's a bounded input.
And here's the other
part of the condition.
Absolute value of hm summed
over all m is finite.
We say that h is
absolutely summable--
absolutely summable.
So what does that do for us?
Well, it actually allows
us to bound the outputs.
So now, it turns
out y of n, that's
the absolute value
of the output.
Well, that's less than or
equal to the absolute value
of this convolution
expression, which
is in turn less than-- well,
it's equal to that, right?
It's equal to that, but it's
less than or equal to this.
Absolute value of
a sum is less than
or equal to the sum of
the absolute values.
And that's less than
or equal to capital M--
this is the max value
that we allowed up there--
times summation hm.
So this whole thing is finite.
So basically, you
can bound the output.
You can guarantee
that the output
is bounded provided these
two conditions are satisfied.
So this is actually a very
important pair of conditions.
It's one that we encounter
all the time and in practice.
And because of this
result, we actually
refer to an LTI
system that satisfies
this absolute
solvability condition.
We say that the LTI
system is bounded
input, bounded output stable--
bounded input,
bounded output stable.
And I've run out of space
from my stable there.
So if somebody tells you
they have a bounded input,
bounded output stable system,
if we're talking about an LTI
system, what they mean is that
that condition is satisfied.
So that's an
important condition.
OK, I have all that on a slide.
But if I race it past you on a
slide, then it's hard to track.
But this is something
that we want to do.
So for instance, if I had an
LTI system whose unit sample
response was the following--
let's say it's 0 for all times
up to and including time 0,
and then it takes the value
1 over n, from then on, OK?
So let's see, one
way to write this
is 1 over n u of n minus 1.
If I tell you that
the h of n is this,
that automatically takes care
of zeroing out everything
from 0 backwards, and then
putting in 1 over n from then
on.
So is that BIBO stable system--
bounded input,
bounded output stable?
Yes?
How many think yes?
You'd like to think it's
stable, because a unit sample
response is decaying.
But actually, it doesn't
satisfy the absolute solvability
condition.
The sum of 1 over n
from 1 to infinity is--
it actually blows up.
It doesn't converge.
If it falls off any
faster than that,
then you're in good shape.
But this is actually bad.
If you had something that
was 1 over n squared--
OK, so this is not BIBO stable.
But if you had 1 over n
squared u of n minus 1,
it is BIBO stable.
If you had, let's say, 1/3
to the n u of n minus-- well,
we'll say u of n,
that's BIBO stable.
So this falls off
as 1 over n squared.
That's fast enough for
the sum to converge.
This falls off
exponentially faster.
It's as a geometric series.
It's a discrete
time exponential.
So that's fast enough.
So that's also BIBO stable.
All right, so this
is time domain.
We know how to analyze
any LTI system with this.
You tell me what the
unit sample response is
and I can tell you what the
output is for any given input.
But this would be a nightmare if
we had to do design with this,
because convolution is not--
it's simple enough to implement
for a particular case,
but it's not a simple
operation to think in terms of.
The reason is that the
output at any one time
is obtained by scrambling
all the inputs for all time,
combining them in this
weighted linear fashion.
And then, if you move
to the next time step,
you're again scrambling all the
inputs, but with the weights
shifted a little
bit, so you've got
to start from scratch again.
So it's very hard to know
what you can say in general
using the time domain.
It's not clear at
all how you'll do
design, for instance, of filters
to filter out noise and so on.
So this is actually--
it's important.
It's a full characterisation
of LTI systems.
But if we had to
stop there, it's
a fair bet that we wouldn't
be anywhere near where
we are for engineered
systems, certainly
not in digital communication.
So the key thing is
actually to start thinking
in terms of frequencies.
So we're going to
look-- we're going
to spend the next
several lectures looking
at the frequency domain.
And so what is the
frequency domain?
Well, we're going to be
focusing, essentially,
on sinusoidal inputs and inputs
that are related to them.
But let me actually just start
back with something simpler.
Here's my question.
And I hope the answer isn't
already on the slides.
Maybe it is.
Is it true that if my input
was periodic-- so for instance,
if I had an input that,
let's say, did this,
it ramped up over
maybe four time steps,
and then started again,
ramping up over 4 times steps,
and continued that indefinitely.
So here's my x of n.
It's an x of n that has
some basic period that
then repeats periodically.
So it satisfies
that condition xn
equals xn plus capital P
for some number capital P
that's the period.
What is capital P in this case?
4?
OK.
So every 4, this repeats.
Is it true that if I had a
periodic input to an LTI system
that I'll get a periodic output?
Any reason I should expect that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Depends on the system.
PROFESSOR: Could you
speak up a little?
AUDIENCE: It depends
on the system.
PROFESSOR: It depends
I'm telling you it's
LTI but nothing more.
So it depends on which
particular LTI system?
That would be my intuition, too.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just like
in the piece that it
can average over a long
enough time sample,
to where it would be constant.
So I'm assuming it's constant.
PROFESSOR: Well, but
that's an average.
That's one number.
What I'm asking you is could
this output as a function
of time also be periodic?
Can you guarantee it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm not
exactly understanding
your prescription.
So are you telling me how
to prove that yn equals
yn plus something for all n?
AUDIENCE: If we
choose enough-- if we
take enough x's can
we make y constant?
PROFESSOR: According to this--
well, I raised the
convolution expression.
But the convolution
expression requires
us to take x's from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
In general, the output at time
n depends on all the inputs.
So it's not clear how
you can block things off.
You had another idea?
AUDIENCE: Well, because it's
time invariant, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
This is a time
invariant system, right?
So if I shifted the
input by capital P,
the output should also
get shifted by capital P.
But shifting the
input by capital
P gives me the same
input back again.
So the response that I
get for that shifted input
must be the old
response that I had,
which tells me that
the output also
has the property that if
I shifted by capital P,
I'd get the same thing again.
So this is guaranteed
to be period capital P.
Now, actually there's
a little twist to that.
Because we usually
think of the period
as being the smallest interval
for which you can repeat.
It's conceivable that this
output has a smaller interval,
and therefore that the
period is some integer
fraction of this capital P.
But this is the general idea.
So you see that just knowing
that the system is LTI,
you can already tell
a lot about what
the response will look like.
One of our favorite
periodic inputs--
well, if I asked
you to tell me what
your favorite periodic
input is, what might it be?
Any-- sorry?
AUDIENCE: Constant input?
PROFESSOR: Constant is good.
That's periodic.
A little less trivial
than constant?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sinusoid, right?
So here's the nice
thing about sinusoids.
It turns out, for an LTI
system, if I put in a sinusoid,
not only is the output
periodic with the same period.
It's also a sinusoid.
So that's an even
greater restriction here.
You see, in this
particular case,
I have an input that's periodic.
I'm guaranteed the output is
periodic with the same period.
But the actual shape
of the waveform
can be all messed
up relative to this.
It may have no obvious
visual relationship to this.
But if you have a
sinusoidal input,
then it turns out
that more is true.
So it turns out, if you put a
sinusoid in, what you get out
is a sinusoid of
the same frequency.
What might change is the
amplitude of the sinusoid
and the phase angle
on the sinusoid.
But it'll be the same frequency
sinusoid that comes out.
So that's a fairly
dramatic restriction.
And that's actually key to
frequency domain methods.
What it means is we can focus
on what an LTI system does
one frequency at a time.
I'll look to see how it
behaves when I excite it with
a particular value of
this big omega here--
that's the frequency--
look at the response.
I know the response will be
exactly at that frequency.
So all I have to capture is
how much did this input get
scaled by--
in other words, how much did
the amplitude change by--
and how much did the
phase get changed by?
I just need to know
the magnitude and phase
transformation of the
cosine at each frequency.
If I know that, I know
everything about the system.
And it decouples my design.
It allows me to think
frequency by frequency when
I design with an LTI system.
So this is actually a
great simplification.
One other remark I've
made here, by the way,
it's certainly the case
in continuous time,
if I gave you x of
t equals cosine,
let's say, omega 0 t plus
theta, this is always periodic.
This is periodic with period
2 pi over little omega--
a little omega 0.
Because any time I increase t
by an integer multiple of this,
I'm going to get
an integer multiple
of 2 pi added into the
argument of the cosine.
So I'll be back where
I started, right?
So this is always periodic.
But with a discrete
time sequence,
you actually have to be
a little more careful.
We can think of some particular
discrete time sequence.
We refer to the omega and
the continuous time case
as the angular frequency
in radians per second.
Here, we're thinking of this
as angular frequency in radians
per sample, for instance,
because the thing it multiplies
is n.
But basically, the units
of big omega are angle.
Well it turns out that this
may not be strictly periodic
in the sense that
shifting it by an integer
will get you exactly
the same waveform.
And that's all related to
whether this frequency--
whether 2 pi over
omega-- the thing
that you would like to compute
as a period-- is rational
or not.
It turns out, if 2 pi over
big omega is rational,
then the period is the
numerator of that rational.
But otherwise,
it's not rational.
But you can think of it
as being samples taken
from some periodic quantity.
So there's an underlying
time varying--
sorry, there's an
underlying continuous time
periodic waveform.
And you take samples of it.
And depending on the frequency
of the underlying sinusoid,
the sequence of samples
may be exactly periodic,
or may be close
to it in the sense
that they're samples taken
from a periodic signal.
In either case, actually, we
tend to not fuss about that.
We'll talk about a cosine like
this as a sinusoid of frequency
omega radians per sample, and
we'll talk about the period
as being 2 pi over
omega even when
it's not strictly periodic.
So 2 pi over omega is
our notion of period.
So a couple of examples
here, you can--
I'll leave you to look
through those on the slides.
But you can easily construct
examples where 2 pi over omega
is rational, and draw a
picture, and convince yourself
that it's actually periodic.
So in this case, for
instance, if big omega--
big omega is whatever
multiplies n,
so it's going to be 3 pi over 4.
3 pi over 4 is big omega.
So now, I need to look
at 2 pi over omega.
And so that's equal to 8 over 3.
The numerator of that
is what the period is.
So if you were to
actually sketch this out,
you would find that every
8 samples, it repeats.
Whereas, if you look
at this example,
the thing that multiplies
in is 3 over 4.
So now, the period 2 pi over
omega is 2 pi over 3 over 4.
So now we're talking
about 8 pi over 3.
That's not rational.
You're not going to get
a periodic sequence.
But we still refer
to 8 pi over 3
as the period of this
discrete time signal, OK?
Just because it comes from
sampling an underlying
continuous time periodic signal.
All right, that's a detail.
I just don't want you to
trip up on that later on.
So here's the basic statement--
what I said earlier.
If you have an LTI system--
by the way, I like to
represent this with an h dot,
so that slipped past there.
I think I've talked
about this before.
Let me not spend time on it--
notation, notation.
So if the input is a sinusoid of
some frequency, and amplitude,
and phase, the
output is guaranteed
to be a sinusoid of the
same frequency, potentially
different amplitude
and different phase.
So what I want to do is
establish that for you,
starting with our time domain
characterization, which
is LTI convolution.
It turns out,
actually, sinusoids
are not the only things
that have this property.
In fact, it might be good for
me to show you another example,
too.
So let me give you another
example of a waveform
that you can put at the input--
or signal that you can put in
the input to an LTI system,
and it comes out the same shape
despite all the convolution.
So here's the example.
Suppose xn is what I think of
as a discrete time exponential.
So this is r to the n
for some real number r.
So maybe-- maybe r is 1/2.
So this is-- so this is xn.
It's a discrete
time exponential.
You're used to thinking of
that as a geometric series.
But when you're talking
about signals and systems,
you like to think of that as
a discrete time exponential.
It does have an
exponential fall off.
What if that goes
in to this system?
Well, the output is
given by this expression
always, for an LTI system.
So let's just plug in what x
is, that summation over all m,
hm, r to the n minus m.
I'm just substituting in
this expression for x of n.
The n piece of this doesn't
depend on the summation index.
So I can actually
simplify this further.
And here's what I have.
So look what's happened.
I sent in a discrete
time exponential.
And out comes the same
discrete time exponential,
but scaled by some number.
This is just a number, right?
It's an infinite sum.
It's just a number.
It works out to be a number.
You'll have to look for
conditions under which it's
guaranteed to exist.
And certainly, if the
system is BIBO stable, and--
well, if the system is
causal, and the exponential
is decaying, then this
is guaranteed to exist.
OK, so here's an example
of another kind of signal--
related to the
sinusoid as we'll see--
that has the property that you
put it through the LTI system.
Despite all this convolution
stuff that's going on,
I don't even have to
know what that h is.
I can tell you right
away that what comes out
is the same
exponential but scaled.
So now, we're going
to try and establish
the property for sinusoids.
And the way to do that--
the efficient way to do that
is actually to work
with exponentials again.
Except they're not exponentials
of the type that I have there.
They're complex exponentials.
Now, when you learn complex
numbers in high school,
maybe you thought you wouldn't
have to deal with them again.
And then you came to calculus
and you had complex numbers,
and you thought
maybe after that,
you don't have to
deal with them again.
So I'm here to tell
you that you're always
going to have to deal
with complex numbers.
So you have to get
comfortable with them.
So we're talking
about, essentially,
points in the plane--
point with a real part
and an imaginary part.
So here's the complex number c.
Here's the real part.
Here's the imaginary part.
I never thought I'd
need to define j,
but actually, it turns out that
if not everyone in the room
is an electrical engineer,
then maybe you're
used to thinking of i as being
the square root of minus 1.
Electrical engineers like
j, because they reserve i
for currents, right?
So j is the square
root of minus 1
in all electrical engineering.
The key identity that you
need is Euler's identity.
Let me actually
write it on the board
and leave it there, because
we'll be coming back to it
multiple times.
Well, actually I can
have it on this board,
because it's really the same.
It's really this picture.
e to the j theta is
some complex number.
Its real part is cosine
theta, and its imaginary part
is sine theta.
That's all that Euler's
identity is saying, right?
Here's a complex number.
Its real part is cosine
theta, its imaginary part
of sine theta.
So what's the magnitude
of e to the j theta?
Every complex number
has a magnitude.
e to the j theta
has magnitude what?
1.
Because it's cosine squared
plus sine squared, right?
And the angle of
e to the j theta--
the angle of a complex
number is just the angle
from the real axis
up to this vector.
So the angle is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm hearing
more complicated answers
than I expected.
Theta, right?
You're right.
It's arctan sine theta over cos
theta, which is theta, right?
All right, so this
is Euler's identity.
And this is really critical.
And if you can
remember this, then you
can remember all sorts
of other identities
that might trip you
up from time to time.
So for instance, let's see,
if I have e to the j theta
1 times e to the j theta 2,
does that simplify to this?
That's OK, right?
That's just combining
the exponents.
Well, expand this out
using Euler's identity.
Expand this out using
Euler's identity.
Euler's identity,
and you discover, for instance,
that cosine theta 1 plus theta
2 equals cosine theta 1, cosine
theta 2, minus sine theta
1 sine theta 2.
OK, you know all
these identities.
But if you're ever pressed to
derive them, the place to start
is Euler's identity.
If you're pressed to
derive Euler's identity,
then maybe go back
to Taylor series.
But if you want to carry
one thing in your head,
carry Euler's identity.
All the rest follows.
All right.
So here is-- well,
actually, let me
make that point a little later.
These are easy.
e to the j0 is just--
this unit length vector
line along the real axis
is just the number 1.
e to the j pi, it's
the unit vector lying
along the negative real axis.
So that's the number
minus 1, right?
So here's how we use complex
exponentials to prove
the result that I claimed
earlier, namely that sinusoids
in gives you sinusoids out.
A sinusoid of a
given frequency in
gives you a sinusoid of
the same frequency out.
What we're going to
do is actually combine
sines and cosines
into one calculation.
This may look a little
funny, because now, we're
suddenly putting a complex
input into this LTI system.
But if you think about the
math that we did for LTI,
it didn't really
care whether we were
feeding in real numbers
or complex numbers.
So we could have
a signal that has
a real part and a complex
part at each time.
Convolution would work
exactly the same way.
We arrived at convolution
through linearity and time
invariance arguments, and all
those work for complex signals.
So we could actually be putting
in a signal of this type
and seeing what comes out.
Well, this is very close to
the calculation we did earlier
with a real exponential.
The only difference now is
it's a complex exponential.
But here's the computation.
We start, as always, with the
time domain representation.
That's convolution.
Substitute in for
x of n minus m.
x of n is this signal here.
I should have
labeled it as x of n.
So just stick x
of n minus m here.
And then, you
discover that there's
a part of this that doesn't
depend on the summation index.
So you pull that out.
So you're left with this
summation inside and this piece
out.
So look what's happened.
You've put in a
complex exponential.
And out comes the same
complex exponential
scaled by something.
What is this
complex exponential?
Well, its real part
is a cosine signal,
and the imaginary part is
a sine signal, all right?
So this object is something that
we'll encounter and use a lot.
It's referred to
as the frequency
response of the system.
You've heard the term used,
undoubtedly, in other settings.
But here's the definition.
It's a function
only of big omega.
Because once you've
summed over m--
little m-- everything
else has gone away.
So only depends on big omega.
And here's what it is.
It's the summation over
all values of m, h of m,
e to the minus j omega m.
That's the frequency response.
So if you give me the unit
sample response of a system,
I can find for you what
the frequency response is.
So let's actually do an example.
Let's see.
Let's take one of your--
let's take an averaging
filter that you've looked at.
To make it easy on you, I'll
sketch it as a function of m.
It doesn't matter
what that's called.
So here's 1/3, 1/3 1/3.
We've come to recognize this as
B unit-sample response of a 3
point averaging filter.
It's a causal 3 point averaging.
So what's the frequency
response of this system?
Well, it's h of big omega.
And then I just follow
this prescription.
So the only values of h
that are non-0 are for m
equals 0, 1, and 2.
So it's going to be 1/3, 1
plus e to the minus j omega,
plus e to the minus j2 omega.
And I'm done, right?
Now, to actually get a feel
for this what you want to do
is write it in different forms.
For instance, a very
useful way to write this
is in terms of the
magnitude and the angle.
So here's a way to represent
any complex number.
This is a complex number, right?
I can write it as magnitude
times e to the j angle.
So that will actually turn out
to be a much more efficient way
to think about
frequency responses.
This is the magnitude of
the frequency response.
And this is the phase.
So how does that bring us
back to sines and cosines?
Let me actually go a little
bit out of order here,
and here's the basic statement.
From the result that
we have up there--
and I'll show you on the
next slide how to derive it--
what you can show is that if you
put a cosine into the system,
what comes out is the same
cosine, except its amplitude is
scaled by the magnitude
of the frequency response,
and the phase angle is increased
by the angle of the frequency
response.
So this is really--
if you know this as a
function of frequency--
if you know the magnitude and
phase angle of the frequency
response as a
function of frequency,
you can describe the response of
the system to any cosine input.
What if the cosine was a
little more complicated
than the one there?
Suppose I had-- suppose I
had cosine omega 0 n plus,
let's say, pi over 4 going in.
What comes out?
What do you think comes out?
Anyone?
I showed you a
particular case here.
How much new work would you
have to do if it was actually
a slightly shifted cosine?
Take a guess.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just replace n in the
output with n plus pi over 4.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
you just change this
by adding in an extra pi over 4.
So what comes out--
that's what you said, right?
Is that what you said?
OK.
Sometimes I'm guessing because
I don't hear that well.
So here's plus the
angle, and then
plus the additional pi over 4.
And this actually
will follow just
from time and variance
of the system.
So you can actually-- so this
is actually pretty general.
If you're going to remember one
thing about frequency response
in terms of what the
operational significance is,
for instance in a
laboratory experiment,
this is the result to remember.
This is why frequency
response is important.
And the proof, very easy.
Once you have the basic result
with exponential inputs,
the proof is easy.
Because a cosine can be
written as the sum of these two
exponentials.
How do I get that?
Just from Euler's
identity, right?
Use Euler's identity for each
of these-- for e to the j, e
to the minus j, when
you add Euler's for this
and Euler's for this, the
sine terms cancel out.
So you get 2 cosine in the
numerator and you divide by 2.
So if you're stuck for a
derivation of a result like
this, go back to Euler's.
So cosine can be
written this way.
So when I feed a
cosine big omega
0n of the input, what
I'm actually feeding in
is a linear combination
of two exponentials.
But I know how to write the
response to an exponential.
If this exponential--
this sum of exponential
goes in, what comes out is the
corresponding sum of responses.
So it will be this exponential
times the 1/2 there,
scaled by the
frequency response.
That's what frequency response
does to an exponential.
And this exponential
comes out the same,
but scaled by the frequency
response-- evaluated
at the frequency of
that exponential.
So maybe you've-- you're having
trouble visualizing the result
that I'm invoking.
But it's the one
that we just proved.
If you have e to the ae
to the j omega n going in,
let's say, at some
particular frequency omega
0 to a system with frequency
response h of omega, what
comes out is the same
exponential that went in,
scaled by the frequency response
evaluated at the frequency
that we're talking
about-- omega 0.
So when I label the system
with the frequency response,
this is a general omega.
But the value of it that I'm
interested in is the value of--
at the frequency of the inputs.
So if the input is e to the
j omega 0n, what comes out
is that same e to
the j omega 0n,
but scaled by the frequency
response at that frequency.
So that's what
I'm invoking here.
Invoking it twice, well,
this is just the real part
of this quantity, because
it's a complex number
and its complex
conjugate, and so on.
So you put it all together,
and you actually very directly
have this result.
So we're using complex
inputs as just a trick
for getting the results
that we'd really
like to get for real inputs.
If you didn't want to do
that, you could actually just
put in the cosine omega 0n, and
crank it all the way through,
and you would get it.
So you could say yn equals
summation over all m, h of m.
Then we have x of n
minus m here, right?
So it's going to be cosine
omega 0, n minus m going in.
And now, use appropriate
algebraic identities and you'll
get the same result.
So we didn't have to use
complex exponential inputs
to get the result. It's just a
convenient way of getting it.
Again, if you're going to
carry one result in your head
in the complex case,
this is the one to carry.
It is very simple.
It says complex exponential in,
you get the same exponential
out.
So let's play a little more
with this particular filter
since we see that magnitude
and angle are so important.
We're talking-- we're back to
this 3 point averaging, right?
Here's the frequency response.
And I'd like to get
the magnitude out.
And you could certainly
use Euler's identity
on each of these pieces,
group all the real parts, all
the imaginary parts, and so on.
It ends up actually
being a bit of a mess
to try and write down cleanly.
So let me show you a trick that
works for this kind of thing.
And it'll give you some
practice in thinking
about these complex
exponentials.
Do you agree that I've just
rewritten the same thing
as I had above?
OK, does this simplify?
Can you write it
as something real?
We've got a complex quantity
and its complex conjugate there,
so we should be able to
collapse them into real, right?
The way you recognize a complex
conjugate is that the j has
gone to a minus j.
So what is this whole thing?
Somebody?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Where
did that come from?
Can I have a hand, just--?
Oh, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so let's say
1 plus 2 cosine omega, right?
So that's simplified nicely.
OK, so are we in a position to
say what the magnitude of h is?
I've got an h that
is represented
as the product of this.
Oh, by the way, sorry, I--
this should just be
a 3 here, not a 1/3.
Everyone shook their
head in agreement
when I wrote that down, but--
what's the magnitude of the
product of two complex numbers?
Is it the product of
the individual ones?
The magnitude of
h is going to be,
let's see 1/3 magnitude e
minus j omega times magnitude
1 plus 2 cosine omega, right?
The magnitude of a
product of complex numbers
is just the product of
the individual magnitudes.
What's the magnitude of this?
1.
So we're actually done.
We actually have a
very simple expression
for the magnitude of
the frequency response
of this moving average filter.
That's all it is.
Oh, sorry, I need
the absolute value.
So let's see, I
think I have that
sketched out in one of these.
I actually have three moving
average filters drawn out here.
The one that I've just
worked out is this case.
This is the 3 point
moving average filter--
a height of 1/3
for each of these
at 0, 1, and 2, and
everything else is 0.
Here is the frequency
response magnitude.
The notation that's used on the
figure is slightly different.
So some people, including me
in the next course I teach,
will write the
frequency response
as this instead of h of omega.
But that's really
unnecessarily fussy.
It's important when you're
talking about z transforms
at the same time
that you're talking
about Fourier transforms.
But for us, it's not important.
So you'll see slightly different
notation, probably in the notes
as well.
But just think of that
as just h of omega.
So here's the filter
we were talking about.
Here, supposedly, is the
frequency response magnitude.
What we should be seeing is
the magnitude of this quantity.
And let me see if
you believe it.
So what we have is--
so what I have is,
at omega equals 0,
I've got something
that starts at 1.
And then, when I get
out to minus pi over pi,
this has come down to
the value minus 1/3.
And so this is what I have for--
this is the quantity
within the absolute sine,
before I take an absolute value.
And when I take the absolute
value, this flips over.
And that's really what
you're looking at.
You're looking at frequency
response magnitude,
which is this.
And you've got to figure
out the phase accordingly.
And that I'll leave you
to do in recitation.
But I want to ask
you one last thing.
Why do I not bother
to plot the frequency
response beyond minus pi to pi?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the reason is that
the frequency response tells us
what the response is to
inputs of this type, right?
The frequency response
says if this goes in,
how much it gets scaled
by when it comes out.
Well, if I increase omega 0 by
an integer multiple of 2 pi,
I get the same
exponential back again.
So there's no new information
outside of minus pi to pi.
Another way to think
of it is we're really
talking about complex
numbers and their angles.
Once you've made a full
circle from minus pi to pi,
there's no new space to cover.
So you'll see frequency
response is only
plotted from minus pi to pi.
All the interesting
action is there.
All right, we'll
develop more intuition
for this in recitation and in
the next couple of lectures.